Speaker 1: Republicans are now staging ridiculous
hearings in New York City on violent crime.
These are Republicans from the House of Representatives.
And you may say, David, wait a second.
House of Representatives, Washington, D.C.,
federal government.
Why are they holding these hearings in New
York City?
The reason they are doing it is because they
are trying to run interference for Donald
Trump's indictment and arrest by attacking
Alvin Bragg with the idea.
Why is Bragg going after Trump when Bragg
has violence in New York City to deal with?
Now, of course, you and I probably see that
and say, wait a second.
Prosecutors can do multiple things at once.
One of the problems we have in the United
States, which I've pointed out, is that there
is too much focus on street crime rather than
corporate, financial and white collar crime.
That doesn't mean we ignore violent crime.
It means that we have a system that at its
systemic structural level focuses on one type
of crime and not the other.
And that leads to a disproportionate focus
on wealthy people I'm sorry, not on wealthy
people, but rather on poor people.
We've talked about this before.
Low effort, low hanging fruit policing, for
example, makes it much easier to just go to
a poor neighborhood and, you know, harass
people, stop and frisk, etc., and not actually
partake in the other types of investigative
work that we should be seeing.
So Alvin Bragg is doing nothing wrong.
But Republicans want to make the case there's
violence in New York and Alvin Bragg is indicting
Trump for nonsense.
The other element to this is that we have
a red state murder problem and a red city
violent crime problem.
But Republicans don't want you to know that.
They want you to believe, oh, it's liberal
cities that are dangerous and that's it.
So let's take this from the top.
NBC News reports Trump Allies Take Fight to
brags Backyard with hearing on New York City
crime.
The Manhattan district attorney prosecuting
Donald Trump highlights new police data that
shows murders and under other violent crimes
have actually fallen in the borough since
last year.
There's a picture on the screen of Republican
Congressman Jim Jordan because he is leading
this these series of hearings.
As absurd as they are, the argument that Republicans
want to make is Democrats are weak on crime
as it is.
Blue cities have a crime problem.
And Alvin Bragg epitomizes this problem by
going after Trump rather than going after
the violent crime.
Well, Eric Adams, the mayor of New York City,
was on MSNBC's.
You see this morning.
And he accurately and rightly pointed out
that not only is this a political stunt, but
there is actually a bigger problem with violent
crime in many Republican cities.
Here's Eric Adams.
Speaker 2: Why?
Let's bring in the mayor of New York City,
Eric Adams.
By the way, what do you think of this field
hearing in your city about crime?
Speaker 3: I think is the highest level of
hypocrisy.
We know that cities all across America are
dealing with the issues around public safety,
particularly the criminal justice system.
And right in the largest city in Ohio.
I was a reporter today, one of the tabloids
of the murders of over 50% in the first quarter.
And so while crime is going down, homicides
are going down here, shoes are going down
here.
Some of the major crimes, you're trending
in the right direction.
So we system crime is going down.
So I think come in here and highlight.
And to brag is it's just really a political
stunt.
Speaker 1: Now, is Eric Adams correct?
Yes, he is.
It is true that in New York City in 2022,
there was a violent crime rate, a homicide
rate of 5.2 per 100,000 people, whereas in
Columbus, Ohio, there was a homicide rate
of 15.4 per 100,000 people.
The homicide rate in 2022 was nearly three
times higher in Columbus, Ohio, than it was
in New York City.
We've talked about both violent and property
crime rates being higher.
In Oklahoma City, a red city in a red state,
then in New York City and New York state.
And then there is also something, as I mentioned
earlier, called the red state murder problem
in 2020.
Per capita murder rates were 40% higher in
states Trump won than in states Biden won
40% higher.
If you look at 2020, at the ten states with
the highest murder rates, eight of them voted
for the presidential nominee from the Republican
Party in every election this century so far.
Now, I don't want to do the thing that the
right does on so many different issues, whether
it's gas prices or debt and deficit and whatever,
and pretend that the entire crime story is
just a matter of when Republicans are in charge,
it's more dangerous because that's actually
not so clearly the case.
And what I mean by that is crime is multidimensional
and very complicated.
Crime can be influenced by many different
factors.
It often also fluctuates from year to year.
When you look at crime, you have to look at
poverty inequality, which we know has a big
impact on crime, education levels, per capita
income, the relationship between political
affiliation and crime rates is one element,
and it's not straightforward.
But the reason I bring all of this up to you
is that the right wing narrative of dangerous
democratic cities or states or whatever, it's
absolutely and completely bogus.
Now, I do want to give you one other.
I don't even know what this is.
I want to advise you of one other way in which
this conversation is often mishandled by many.
There's a game that can be played, which is
you can say, Oh, you know what?
Red states are far more dangerous on average
than blue states.
Okay.
So then Republicans will come in and say,
no, no, no, no, no.
But the problem is, even within the red states,
most of the violence is in the blue cities.
But then you can come back and say, well,
hold on a second.
Just the fact that the violence is in the
cities doesn't really mean it's because of
Democrats, because much of this policy is
set at the state level and the state legislature
and the state Senate are Republican.
And then you can go back and say, well, within
the cities, the crime is mostly within the
districts that are from Democratic city councilors.
Okay.
I think you get the point that this can be
sliced and diced a whole bunch of different
ways.
So my message here isn't to say it is because
of Republicans necessarily in every case that
violent crime and homicide and all these things
are higher.
The point is the right wing story about crime
in Democrat cities, so-called, is completely
and totally wrong.
But what this is all about.
Is interference, running interference for
Trump and his indictment.
When Trump was arrested and indicted a week
and a half ago, the strategy was very clear.
What can Republicans in the House do to help
Donald Trump?
And one of the things Jim Jordan has chosen
to do is to have these absurd hearings in
New York City rather than in Washington, DC,
where they should be in order to try to distract.
I don't think it'll work.
We'll be watching them closely and we'll have
clips for you later this week.
The David Pakman Show is independent media.
We do depend on your support to do what we
do, and the best and most direct way to support
our work is simply to get a membership at
Join Packman AECOM.
We do an extra show every day for our members.
Today.
I've got actually, I think much of today's
bonus show will be some stories from my trip.
And it was quite a trip, including a an interesting
confrontation with a customs officer, which
I think will titillate many.
All of that and more on the bonus show.
But you can sign up at join Packman dot com
and you can use the coupon code in date if
you would like.
Indict actually and indicted both work.
Join Pacman dot com